how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it's been a rough time to be a Marvel
fan recently there has been a lot of
excitement around phase four however
unfortunately Marvel is making us wait
an entire year after the release of
Avengers in Game four phase four to
start an entire year without a film in
the MCU it's been a little rough but
luckily for us
May first is not that far away where we
will see Natasha Romanoff hit the big
screen again kicking off phase four in
Black Widow now May first still is many
months away but I have hope for you
today news about the Black Widow trailer
this [ __ ] is giving me everything
quick reminder to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the MCU many of you
have asked me if I've heard anything
about the Black Widow trailer and when
we can expect it and I finally have an
answer for you you see everybody has
been wondering when we are going to get
the Black Widow trailer but we've kind
of known all along and this is something
that MCU cosmic has recently pointed out
and this is because Marvel has a pattern
when it comes to trailers they do things
the same way so if we take a look at
Marvel Studios releasing trailers before
2017 they always did it the same way for
a big may release in the MCU they would
always release the first teaser trailer
for that movie at the end of October and
this was their strategy the pattern that
they would always use for their May
releases and they continuously did this
they did this for the first Avengers
film Iron Man 3 Captain America the
Winter Soldier the next Avengers film
age of Ultron and Captain America Civil
War but then after Civil War Marvel
changed it up a little bit instead of
releasing the first teaser trailers for
their big main movies in October they
begin to do this in late November /
early December so for their next big
movies that they had come in and made
they released the first teaser trailers
for them in November and December the
first teaser trailer for guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 was on December 3rd the
teaser trailer for Avengers infinity war
was on November 29th and of course the
long-awaited
Avengers in-game trailer was on December
seven so Marvel has only ever released
the first teaser trailer for their
upcoming May films in October November
or December
well October has now come and passed and
obviously we did not get a teaser
trailer so that means that the first
teaser trailer for Black Widow the first
teaser trailer for the first MCU phase
for movie is going to be late November /
early December and guys this is
something that Marvel has done every
year without fail
so we could be getting the Black Widow
trailer as early on as this month if it
is not this month then it is going to be
in early December so we don't have much
longer to wait until we get the very
first teaser trailer for Black Widow the
very first teaser trailer for the first
film in phase four reminder about my
xbox one and ps4 giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your favorite superhero or
villain and let me know how excited you
are about seeing the Black Widow teaser
trailer very soon as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof